we get tons of inquiries on a weekly
basis
kind of just asking you know who is the
go-go
what's his background story how did he
get to where he is this video is going
to be an odd one for me
because in real life i'm a pretty quiet
person
i don't really like talking about myself
or drawing attention to myself
i don't even really like social media so
having this youtube channel grow to the
size that it is
is well ironic
it's led to some interesting outcomes
i've had the privilege of speaking at
international events
giving tv and radio interviews and all
that kind of stuff
but honestly i just enjoy staying in the
background
so the reason i'm doing this video is
that a lot of people have been saying
they want to know more about me
this video is for you guys most of you
have no idea who i
am yet over 2.4 million of you have
decided to subscribe to me anyway
so what this really means is that the
content is speaking for itself
which is pretty awesome i appreciate all
of you so much
and thank you for sticking around
so who am i well my name is digogoltrade
and that's spelt d-a-g-o-g-o
and first i think i should tell you a
bit about my background because many
people find it confusing
some people think i'm american while
others think i'm from britain
but it's a bit more complicated than
that
i was born in mumbai india in 1990 and
lived in england
scotland and other parts of europe then
finally moved to perth australia when i
was still a child
so my accent is perceived differently
depending on who you ask
and strangely enough that's a bit of a
central theme about me people perceive
me differently depending on the
preconceived notions that they have
both my parents are from nigeria so my
ethnicity is nigerian
but my nationality is australian
growing up with such a unique background
and being different from everyone else
around me was hard but it ended up being
a gift
it meant that from a young age i was
forced to think differently
i didn't have the luxury of being like
anyone else there was no mode of group
thinking that i could fall into
i always had to think for myself and
that made me have a different
perspective on most things
it's so funny because in today's
hyperpolitical climate
a lot of people watch my content and get
confused one video they think that i'm a
communist
and in the very next video they think
that i'm a staunch right winger
and that's kind of the point if you look
at me through a bipartisan lens
you'll often get me wrong this instagram
comment sums it up perfectly
you're an enigma some days i think you
lean left
some days i think you're quite
libertarian slash u.s constitutional
conservative
frankly i think that i'm blessed that i
don't fall into these belief sets
and it's mostly to do with my unique
upbringing but i digress
so a bit about where i live perth is a
unique city
and i do admit it's a beautiful place
its industry is mainly driven by the
resource sector
and has a slower pace of life for a
population of about 2 million
most shops close at 6 pm and restaurants
at 10 pm
it's a very insular city and is just
about the most isolated city on the
planet
the nearest other city is over two
thousand kilometers away or 1
300 miles the downside for me is that
i'm far away from all of the tech action
globally
but the plus side is at least right now
we've been pretty insulated from covert
thus far
people in perth tend to be pretty
uniform in the life that they lead
so the cold fusion channel coming out of
perth has been shocking to many
australians when they find out
if you're not australian let me know if
you've heard of perth city i don't know
how famous it is on a global stage
okay so continuing on with my background
so growing up my dad was a mechanical
engineer who worked offshore for a major
oil and gas company
and that's why i moved around so much as
for me
i was always curious and gravitated
towards science and tech as far back as
i can remember
i used to modify radios and build little
electric cars
just to see how things worked then in
there was a tv show that changed my life
it was robot wars
a program from the uk that was aired on
perth tv on saturday mornings
i would often get up to watch it and was
just amazed at how robotics however
primitive
was being turned into a sport
100 hours over four months to prepare
getting them
shattered in seconds oh how
[Applause]
oh you shouldn't laugh look at that
legging away cassie's grown fights back
against cat three get off there
[Applause]
i was inspired and decided to build my
own at around the age of 10
and the name of this robot was cold
fusion
i learnt a great deal while building it
and if i had any questions
i would just ask my dad i'd ask him
about anything to do with science
and he would always be able to give the
answers derived from first principles
so that was a cool thing to have before
google my father
was really good at explaining things so
much so that other students would line
up to get tutoring while he was still a
student himself
this tutoring wasn't official people
around the university had just heard of
him
back in the early 1980s this university
was the best in the country and was hard
to gain entrance into
there were lecturers from scotland and
wales yet students still came to my
father to gain a clearer understanding
he cleaned up pretty much every
engineering award and has a pile of them
recently one student that he'd helped
even flew back to thank my dad on his
way to japan
because he was now consulting on behalf
of nigeria for the japanese government
he'd been looking for my dad since 1982
when my dad quit his engineering job he
went on to lecture thermodynamics and
engineering statics dynamics at
university in australia
all of this is to say that asking
questions at a young age and getting
robust answers
really fed my curiosity i ended up
studying mechanical engineering at the
university of western australia
it was at this time that i started my
youtube channel
it was really just for fun and i didn't
think much of it
i really just created it to show some
mods that i'd made for android phones
probably the first break i had was in
2012.
it was an interesting time back then i
realized that phones were becoming
increasingly powerful
so i asked myself the question could you
modify a samsung phone so much
that it could function like a pc
i made a video showing my findings and
most people had no idea that things like
this were possible
but fast forward eight years and samsung
has released a full system to turn your
phone into a pc
during this time of the channel i
learned how to research discern
knowledge and think critically within my
engineering degree so it wasn't hard to
apply these principles to the youtube
channel
i could also see that the smartphone
space on youtube was going to get very
crowded in the next couple of years
and i felt like it was time for
something new
after finishing my engineering degree i
studied post-graduate business and
marketing and the scope of the videos
widened
the videos began to focus on how some of
the biggest companies they were all
familiar with
started a sort of perspective changer to
uncover their vast size
but humble beginnings this became the
how big series in 2013.
one of these early videos got featured
on time.com the reason was
it turned out that i was doing something
that hadn't really been done on youtube
back seven years ago
it was an eye-opener for a lot of people
it's cool now to see that youtube is
full of this kind of content these days
i got a lot of encouraging comments at
the time which is one of the most
important factors that kept me
continuing
after finishing my post-graduate i
worked in an oil and gas firm for about
a year
but it wasn't for me i decided to do
youtube full-time
i never learned how to do voice-overs or
edit or mix audio or anything
i kind of just figured it out as i went
along and i think that's an important
point
when figuring out how to get started on
something one of the best ways is to
simply get out there and do it
don't wait for anyone obviously you're
not going to be great when you begin
but there's so many resources out there
to learn skills so much more than i had
when i was studying
as time passed i thought i could do more
with the videos that i was making
i widened the scope even further to
eventually cover the latest research in
different fields
the history of different products and
seminal points and technology
fascinating stories and scandals in
business and economics
the rise and fall of companies
understanding emerging technologies like
blockchain
and so on really at its core
it all comes down to my fascination with
how things work
and why they work all the way from my
childhood i always try to learn as much
as i can
for those of you who have read my book
new thinking you've got a pretty good
idea of how i think
and why i find the world so fascinating
i always have the big picture in the
back of my head
[Music]
a lot of people think that cold fusion
videos are done by a team
but in reality until 2019 it was just me
i had to play the role of researcher
script writer
editor and narrator it was a lot of work
and i would burn out every few months
though in the past year i've been so
grateful to have a researcher and
scriptwriter
and sequencing editor to help out with
some of the videos so i can produce more
without being burnt out
for some videos i also consult with
people working or studying in a
particular field to make sure that the
information is accurate
still i'm looking for ways to improve so
in that spirit i've decided to work on
building a community platform
where like-minded people whether
professionals in industry or just those
interested in science and technology can
discuss ideas and research
and post future video suggestions it's
still in the works but i'm sure i'll
have more to say on it soon
so why are the videos branded cold
fusion tv with the tv part
this is a youtube channel after all well
from the beginning i've branded these
videos as cold fusion tv
because the content is set up like a
traditional tv channel
i cover an unusually wide range of
topics that is
the videos will always be made with my
particular type of style
but they're on completely different
things only bounded by four pillars
science technology business and history
i think usually most youtube channels
would stick to just one of those
[Music]
it's been both a blessing and a curse
because i know i have different groups
of people subscribed for different
things
so it makes it hard for you count wise
and it's like having four channels at
once
but it's one of those things that makes
the channel unique and absolutely
rewarding for those who watch all the
different kinds of videos i have to
offer
for the future i hope to keep making
good content and i strive to get better
as i go
eventually i do want to turn this into
something much bigger but that's for the
future a youtube influence for me was
vsauce
the way michael stevens made knowledge
fun and entertaining was second to none
as for my inspiration in the style of
making these videos most of my
inspiration comes from the past
the educational programming of the late
80s 90s and early 2000s
a less in-your-face approach clear and
concise
and seemingly more sincerity all the way
back in 2013 when i started branching
out
i saw that there was a space for this on
youtube that wasn't being filled
so that's about it but one thing i would
like to mention is that i also compose
and produce music
my first and only break was back in 2012
when i got featured on the youtube
channel majestic casual
that was really cool for me music is my
other passion
in fact i did start another channel
before cold fusion and this was a music
channel where i played music and
reviewed guitars
and i'm not going to say the name of
that channel because it's too
embarrassing
though if you do want to hear the music
i produce i recently made a two hour mix
of my compositions
people say that they can hear my
personality in the music which is
impressive for never meeting me because
it's kind of true
oh and the podcast so many people have
been asking me what happened to that
and it's a story for another video it's
a messy situation
but the bottom line is i hope to get it
up and running again soon in a different
form
anyway that's about it i hope you
learned something about the channel
or at least feel like you got to know me
a bit better now i just want to say
another huge thank you to all of you
again
from my earliest subscribers to those
who just subscribed
none of this would be possible without
all of you
i'll leave you with some snippets of a
podcast i did in new york in october
last year
i've released parts of it on my
instagram but you'll get to see more
here
alright thanks for watching and i'll see
you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one you know
who is the gogo what's his background
story how did he get to where he is
i thought this would be a good
opportunity for him and i to kind of
have a discussion
and give you guys that background behind
him uh how do you feel about that to go
go
sounds great let's do it um so the first
video i made was probably like um
a review of a bass guitar i think
i think that was the first one i and was
just like youtube just came out yeah
this was like 2006 2000 yeah something
like that
okay yeah and what made you want to post
it onto youtube
because i i fell in love with youtube
from the moment
so okay i was so fascinated with youtube
that
you know there's uh like the zune and
like uh creative mp3 players that
could play video back in the day yes
yeah i would each day i would download a
whole bunch of youtube videos convert it
and put it on that so i can watch after
school
really back then data was like a
thousand dollars per gift yeah
there's no way yeah streaming a music
video on a youtube i mean on a
smartphone was just
that was nice on a phone was hard um
so yeah like back in the day i got into
that i was just observing the community
and i was like hey look i
you know i could do this like no one
could watch the video it doesn't really
matter i just kind of want to do it
so yeah that's important i feel like
that's how a lot of things start right
like
you don't necessarily think oh this is
gonna be a million dollar idea someday
or one day i'm going to get to 2 million
subscribers or
anything like that like a lot of people
even when you look at the silicon
silicon valley startups and everything
like that they kind of just started
because
they wanted to and whether people were
going to watch or buy
or use it or whatever the cases kind of
didn't matter yeah was that
something like does that all run along
the lines of what you're talking about
did you think when you started like well
so the same is true for cold fusion like
i enjoy the content that i
do make and like i wouldn't really
rather be doing anything else because
you know i think we're in a very
interesting time
uh right now in terms of what's
happening with science and technology
and we're at
a complete would you say hockey stick
moment in terms of all this
all this all these crazy ideas that are
starting to become realized and we're
like
once in a lifetime opportunity we are
the humans here at this turning point
which no one else has the opportunity to
to be at least throughout the whole of
history no one's had this kind of motion
so
i'm here at this point trying to
document it
and research it investigate be at the
cutting edge and see what's going on and
it's just fascinating so
how can you not enjoy that you know
could not agree more it is